The joe rogan experience.
What was tell what happened with the dense,
you have someone hostage.
Can you talk about that?
Can you talk about what apps you 87 I was 27 years old,
whatever.
I was working in boulder.
I was going to school at night and I was snorting coke with three hands and
fucking uh,
got involved with some kid and he was going to rob his roommate and ended up
robbing them,
both of them.
That's the guy that I had a part in.
It was going to rob me.
What a tangled web we weave when we tangled to deceit and it just so happens
that the guy got caught.
Like I told,
I told him the guy didn't want nothing to do with it,
even though I had the coke with me,
I sent the coke to ask him,
but the other guy,
they got to tried to rob me.
He ended up getting pulled over with the guy we kidnapped in the trunk of his
car,
all fucking bangles up and shit.
So I got arrested for the kidnapping,
kidnapping too and everything.
But you know what?
I fucked up.
It wasn't because I fucked up.
It wasn't because America,
listen bro,
I tend to seven.
I got a ticket this morning for $200 10 cents seven this morning.
For what?
Fuck you.
Buckets were sleeping.
I was going to Tai Chi at seven so I had to drive there.
So my wife said,
if you have to go to the [inaudible] seven you might as well drop me off at the
train station.
I usually walk them every morning to the train station,
but I drove her.
There was a lunch truck there I couldn't pull over,
so I pulled by where she crosses the street.
When I made the right,
when I made the left,
there was a cop behind me.
He goes,
Bro,
the bus drivers complain.
He goes,
it's a thousand dollar ticket.
I have to give you a $200 ticket for parking instead.
Is that okay?
And I took the ticket and I was not angry at him.
I went to [inaudible].
I did my thing.
I didn't mention that he did his job.
This is America.
He did his fucking job.
You follow him saying to you?
A lot of people would of got pissed off at this guy for pulling me over.
He did his fucking job.
You know when I kidnapped that guy,
I kidnap them.
I did that.
I got four years.
I got all fucking easy.
They should have called me in there for 10 fucking years,
but people don't really see much time.
Did you actually do 18 months?
16 months?
That's a long time.
It costs me two years of my life.
You don't know what your life,
how precedent.
Horrible.
No,
it wasn't horrible.
It let's do it standing on my head,
but
I could do that timely time,
bro.
And you do time guys.
Like you'd only it just another day in paradise.
They're going to take us to a place where we get the bullshit about Jujitsu
instead of two hours a day,
eight hours a day.
You follow me and you eat and whatever.
Your freedom gets lost,
which sucks,
but it's the people at home.
It's not you or whatever.
I can do whatever the fuck I get,
Bro.
My jeans are from Cuban motherfucker telling me about,
I smoked the weed.
Castro smoked before he went to the mountains to take over.
You understand me now?
What was a typical day in prison like for you at that six month you're in there
six months.
What's a typical day live in like a doctor.
He liked him,
Bro.
You gotta remember I went to prison for four years.
I got sentenced,
but guess what?
I became,
I became a standup comic.
I learned how to do standup in prison on Thursday nights.
They used to have movie night.
I didn't even know that dog.
They used to have movie night on Thursday night.
So the projector would always fuck up like Ustream and would always fuck up.
Joey talking to the microphone.
It would always fuck up.
So on Thursdays the people just jokingly,
I would always go,
what the fuck is wrong with the projected no.
Everybody would say Cuba get up there and talk.
So I would go up there on Thursday nights.
It was like,
you know,
you want your people and like a hundred of them were black so they called cubic
walk down and talk.
And I would make fun of the black guys.
Like what would it be?
What would you say?
You know,
we make fun of the kitchen,
the kitchen of your standup career.
You're getting those 10 we used to make for the ice roles.
I fucking,
the first day in prison,
they may be a baker.
You know,
you don't,
you don't tell people what you want.
It's like Cuba.
Like yeah,
the outside that was a mechanic really.
Well in here you're a baker.
Here's a book,
learn how to make bagels.
Rolls.
Dog almost blew up the kitchen.
Right?
These mother fuckers afternoon,
they fired me as a baker and they made me a fucking dishwasher at a stock room
quite right.
So I was a dishwasher,
the stock room cloak and whenever they had shitty meals,
the guys I knew when they were going through the line,
I would yell,
don't do it.
So I would go go.
How often were the meals?
Three times a week.
But it didn't matter because at lunch time I was allowed to go to the store for
15 minutes.
I worked it out.
Well,
I had a drive to take garbage out,
so I would go to the store for 15 minutes.
Not only that,
I would call it my own at the Chinese restaurant.
So it would be ready by the time I got there.
So I would go back to the prison with Chinese food and groceries.
That's how strong I was in there plus fuck around and call us.
They were doing steroids and selling drugs in prison ways.
Like a motherfucker.
I was in the stock room clerk so they had to pay me rent.
So how cause they never,
once you stopped,
you stopped.
I would say you,
yeah,
I'll,
I'll hold your voice.
You got to get $3.
You know,
you gotta give me some cigarettes.
I had roids cigarettes,
I had pills in their lap.
They weren't mine.
They just belong to other people.
But you put them on the pallets.
So I would give them a key whenever they need it to go take shit out.
So they were the connection.
I was the,
no,
I was the holdup.
Plus,
did they get the steroids in?
Somebody had to put it up their ass.
I don't know.
I never imagine shooting a steroid in nearby.
How do they smuggled it in again?
Up the rest of it.
Then they get,
then they put it where that contact visits,
right.
You'd do is you take your fucking kid and you fill his pockets with the yummy
this and why you're making out with your husband.
You said you want to see the kid and you pass the kid to the husband and he
takes the drugs that did.
It gives you back.
That's,
that's how Henry Hill did it.
That's how they do it.
Same Shit.
It's no,
you can bro.
There's more drugs on the inside.
That was the ones on the outside and to boot.
This was a minimum security camp.
We had contact visits.
When you have a contact visit,
there's parties every night.
These motherfuckers.
That's the first time I did it,
but I was like,
the second time I did heroin was it,
and I didn't,
couldn't do a needle.
So the Mexican was,
took a Mexican thing,
a heroin melted it.
I had to put like a funnel in mind.
Those made out of paper when they dripped to them my nose and I got up,
I had like candle wick,
Bro,
what the fuck is this?
They're like,
that's heroin man.
Be Cool.
I was like this like a day.
And then the white dudes,
Mike,
it gimmie speed and they would play basketball all fucking night.
They'll be out there
and I'd be out there with them.
Huffington post every week was a new adventure,
every drug,
but the drug
was out there
fucking
minimum security prison where everyone's partying and it took just the greatest
time ever.
But I let it take up on like when you get,
when you,
you know,
you get released.
It's like,
are the ones that I went to a funeral.
You got talk in the mic.
People keep complaining about it.
I was,
I was at,
when I go to the halfway house,
it was even better because I started loaning money out to the Invictus as a loan
shark fix.
Yeah,
because they want to go on,
but if your rent's not paid on Thursday,
not allowed for the weekend,
so the rent would be $65 I give him 65 and [inaudible] 92 you know what I'm
saying?
Like I'm going to give you $65 but you gotta give me 92 tomorrow and I had 10
guys on that role.
I was a fucking machine in there.
Gamma had at the camp,
the biggest scam I had was with,
there was an old Italian dude from Brooklyn,
he was like a half a mobster and he had pool cards and he would only do one card
a week.
You would make like 30 bucks.
And I went up to him,
I go,
Bro,
you have a problem with these cards.
I go,
you're giving them to white guys.
You're not getting the black population.
You got to get in the fucking specs.
And he goes,
I don't know.
They won't talk to me.
I said,
give me the fucking cards.
We're going to go partners.
He went from selling one card every Monday they're doing 10 with me.
Cause I had the brothers,
I had the Puerto Ricans,
I had the whites at everybody and it was amazing.
That's why I really learned that I could really fucking do this.
So on Thursday nights they would say Cuba,
fuck the movie.
Just go up there and talk about the kitchen.
And they were all,
all the yarns,
but y'all don't do it.
It was fucking hysterical.
Talk about
that.
And then I had this one crazy black guy.
This guy was Anton Spencer,
his name was Spencer Antwan from New Orleans and he was crazy.
And he called me,
he told me that he was in there for eight years but involuntary manslaughter.
And he was my mentor.
That was my dog Jack.
He was fucking nuts.
And he would tell me like one day some guy nailed him $2 and he comes to the
kitchen.
He goes,
but you see that guy?
And I go,
no,
I think he's packing and leaving.
This motherfucker went and got a knife.
He got them at the gate as the guy was getting out of jail.
He's like,
motherfucker,
you better get my $2.
I was blown away.
I'm like,
this guy was old and his parents and family had money there.
That's like the best attorney from brothers got killed.
Somebody but his hands and he got eight years.
Wow.
A black guy.
And,
and and uh,
in La,
downtown La,
because I was in a federal place.
He beat him with his fucking hands and got say eight years for voluntary
manslaughter.
He had like $50,000 attorney's he's got,
but he had a knife.
He got a gold tooth in his mouth.
He was one of those brothers and shifted his eyes would go crazy.
I went in there every Thursday I get on stage and then one day this is fucked up
Joe Rogan.
This is why I really dig it because one day guy in the library,
it was like a nerdy dude.
The guy that ran the library and I was friends with them.
We did acid.
He was very into Nostradamus and you know,
he was intelligent but he had just,
he had some problem or some,
he went to prison.
And the funny thing was that one day he came up to me and the jail and a
notebook was a big thing and I was getting ready to get out and I never even
thought about it.
He came up to me and then he goes,
hey bro,
I got you a notebook.
And I go,
what's the notebook for?
It goes,
so when you get out you could write some jokes.
He goes,
he goes,
every week you write jokes.
I never see the notebook.
And I looked at him and I go,
I don't even right and this motherfucker went nuts.
He goes,
you don't right.
And you go up there every week and do that.
He goes,
when you get out of here,
you were,
it was like an angel.
It was like an angel.
I never seen the guy again.
I never heard from him again.
He just goes,
what I watched you do.
You really need to write and get it together.
Wow.
Cause you have a gift.
Just pursue this and that guy never even talked to me like he never used to talk
to me.
I just set it out of the blue.
I got blue,
came up to me one day.
He goes,
Hey,
I got your notebook,
the black guy,
white guy,
white nerdy guy.
That was like a really nerdy guy that would always roll his own cigarettes or
some random guy came up.
Do you think that if you didn't go to prison,
if he didn't have that experience of talking in front of those people that you
probably never would have done standup over,
stand up something that was in the back of your head anyway,
it was in the back of my head.
The prison really woke the animal up because not only I had thought I bro,
if any,
because you had to be funny before prison buddy who heard the niggas crazy by
Richard Pryor.
You had to think of,
he pushed it so hard on that before prison.
I thought I was always good at at the Deli.
I was always loved telling stories.
Yeah,
I was always good with that shit.
And then the thing that really got me was when you go to prison,
they do a diagnostic on you and I like to get an attorney now.
A really,
that's the only thing that irks me about my life.
Like a lot of times people say,
oh I slept with this guy with me is I always wanted to know what's on that
paperwork because it was an intense psychological evaluation.
It just wasn't a guy with a piece of paper saying,
what do you think when you see a star?
Like they put shit in my head,
electrodes and all this shit.
It was three days of mental testing and it was eating me alive and I wanted to
know,
I kept asking the counselor who was from Mississippi,
he hated black people.
He hated specs.
He told me to my face,
my counselor told me cause I hate,
he goes,
I hate all you bug fuckers.
Spics and Nigga.
I mean that's how it goes.
Oh mark.
And he said to me,
he goes,
I go broke.
What he,
his name was mister blue.
I go,
what are you going to fucking tell me?
What's on there and one day he's like,
you really want me to table time here,
bug fucker.
That's what he would call me to my face bug fucker.
He goes,
I'll tell you what time to hit Mr. Buck fucker.
It said that if you really wanted something and I had it that you would take it
from me.
He goes,
no,
you do what the fuck you want with that.
And they threw me out of his office and I felt like a thief for three days.
That's what I read at that.
But what he was trying to tell me was that anything I wanted in my life,
that's what that said,
that I could do anything you want.
You could do do it.
That's what he was saying.
That's what he was trying to beat around and like we call calling your bug
fucker.
No,
by saying what he said,
lady came up to me and he goes,
hey,
did you understand where I was going with that?
He goes,
you're a smart guy.
You're not one of these guys use,
you know,
don't want to experience.
Tell us about so first standup Gig.
Do you remember it?
Yeah,
I remember.
What made you call up that night?
Do you consider the ones in prison knew first standup gigs?
I'm talking about first official out of club,
like your first time you went up,
but it's,
I'm thinking that if you did it,
how many times did you do doing in prison?
Do you really were doing like opening night tonight?
I was doing every Thursday for sure.
If that's not a movie I've done a bunch of times.
The material.
Did you have material planned out?
Did you have stuff that you repeated?
What was the first club was fun.
You don't imagine repeating the joke in front of those yachts and all those
crazy don't Mexicans.
That's the first time I really do about the whole heritage and they would sneak
in fucking Green Chili burritos.
Tremendous.
Really?
What Joe,
who had the best tattoo artists?
Was it the Mexican Mexican's?
Mexicans always have wild tattoo generations of Mexicans.
At one time I was in jail with the grandfather,
the ILS,
the father and the son.
Well,
wow,
that's really neat.
You start seeing that thing you'll,
and he's been a movie,
right?
Like this is fucking crazy.
And I always wanted to shoot somebody and be a criminal that at that point I
didn't.
You know,
I always thought about that my life deserve more than to spend it in here.
That's what prison did for me,
Bro.
It was,
if people can look through and go,
how bad was prison?
Prison is how bad you make it for me,
for fucking me.
It opened my eyes.
I became a standup comic.
[inaudible]
oh shit.
Itunes or recording to server the fuck outta here.
Server.